Aaaah le Brésil
Le magnifique pays ensoleillé de Pelé,
???
Et la plus grande statue de Jared Leto du monde.
Pour prouver mon dévouement à l'armée des fans de Deadpool brésiliens
J'ai passé au moins 20 minutes sur Google Translate
Ainsi que d'incalculables heures à regarder des telenovelas
Pour apprendre absolument tout sur votre langue
Eh ouais.. "Brasil"
Le p'tit filou en rouge apprend à parler portugais.
Okay, avec un peu de chance mon accent sera pas trop mal.
Veux-tu mon corps, sur le tien, pour l'éternité
Et bien réalisons ce rêve
Cette année à la Comic Con Brésilienne
J'envoie quelques tatoueurs à peu près bons
s'éclater, comme Picasso sur sa toile, avec votre peau
Laissant leurs aiguilles pleines d'encre danser sur votre corps tel Shakira dans une pub de soda
En plus, ils sont totalement gratuits, ils ne vous coûteront rien
Vous n'aurez qu'à signer un contrat et à lancer les dés pour pas chopper d'hépatite
Parlons options, parce que quand même c'est le genre de décision qui nous suit longtemps
Amour : comme l'amour que je porte pour ma main droite ou la danse de la samba à poil
Famille : et surtout ta mère, wow, elle fait de supers petits déjeuners
Fierté : pour ton pays et son taux d'exportation record de...
mannequins
Prison : que ce soit ta première fois ou ta dernière, c'est là-bas que tu reçois
les meilleurs câlins
Regarde moi directement dans les tétons, et dis moi que j'ai pas géré ça
Maintenant qu'est-ce que t'attends ?!
Va sur ce site et réserve toi une place
Et assure toi de ???
Les places sont limitées, alors dépêche toi
Parce que je crois qu'on peut dire qu'il n'y a rien
de comparable à une folle journée, ou nuit, au Brésil
Pour se faire un souvenir à savourer toute sa vie
Demande à l'équipe masculine américaine de natation de 2016
je déconne
Ils trouveront sûrement un petit mytho
Salut salut !